Paradigm shifts don't come along too
often in our industry he had a paradigm
shift in the Canon 5D Mark II came out
the first full-frame sensor that can do
video he had a paradigm shift and the
red came out first compressed raw codec
on a camera that could do higher than 4K
Imaging he had a paradigm shift and the
Alexa came out the first camera that
made it okay to not shoot on film for
your big budget movies well DJI has come
along with a new machine here they're
not really known for making cameras but
guess what they just invented a camera
that not only has one new paradigm shift
in it but three Paradigm shifts it's
pretty crazy take a look at the DJI
Ronin 4D
foreign
I'm not exaggerating here this camera is
going to completely change how we shoot
videos I'm going to tell you why
so you think about companies like Sony
or Canon they release cameras almost
every year they have constant updates
coming out the thing is as they do those
updates the evolution of the cameras is
iterative oh we got a 4K sensor now it's
a 5k sensor now it's a 6K sensor oh we
could record at 72 frames per second at
Full Resolution now it's 96. it's all
these little tiny steps they keep
getting better they're nice cameras but
if they just went out and made the
perfect camera right from the get-go
well they wouldn't have an updated
camera to sell you the next year DJI
here has done away with that entirely
they're like well what if we just
rethought the entire system and then
made all that into one camera
so let me talk about these Paradigm
shifts right three Paradigm shifts well
that's six three Paradigm shifts what
could those possibly be
all right Paradigm Shift number one
you've all used gimbals or seen gimbals
before right it's a bunch of little axes
with gyroscopes and it keeps your camera
stabilized in the center by
counteracting the movement that you make
right now you have to put your camera in
a Gimbal and DJ I was like you know what
what if we put the gimbal on the camera
so they basically have a camcorder body
here and the gimbal is built into the
front of it this is the Zen news X9 if
you guys ever worked with an Inspire
drone well those have a Zenius gimbal on
them this is the brand new ones full
frame sensor Gimbal and it's right here
built into the camera and if using the
DJI lenses we don't have to rebalance it
you can just swap lenses and keep
shooting that's been one of the hugest
pains in my butts when it comes to
gimbals is rebalancing every time you
want to change your focal length you
gotta rebalance every time you want to
put something on or off the camera you
gotta rebalance every time you sneeze
every time an hour passes by every time
the temperature changes you gotta
rebalance the camera well I'm
exaggerating a little bit but
rebalancing is a huge pain in the butt
with this new camera you don't have to
rebalance it you're like that's cool
Nico but I can rebalance a gimbal it's
not the end of the world but you know it
is the end of the world your little
gimbal bounce I can always tell it's
gimbal footage you know it's not shaky
but it definitely has this up and down
movement because you know what it's not
a steady cam all it does is stabilize
this guy but it doesn't stabilize any of
this right you gotta get a big expensive
camera for that to get that Hollywood
look so DJI is like you know what
now we gotta stabilizer arm that's right
this gimbal has a fourth dimension
basically DJI I looked at the looked at
the videos of chickens and they were
like hahaha you should put a camera on
their head and then they're like their
Engineers took it really seriously and
they did that
there's actually a sensor down here on
the bottom basically taking from their
drone technology
in order to tell distance and it can
tell its distance from the ground so use
that to gauge its height for this head
and you can actually change different
methods here we can actually lock it so
it keeps the z-axis locked in space just
like the chicken head or we can put on
follow and it stabilizes any vertical
bumps
another reason that having a gimbal
built into this camera makes it special
is that it unlocks tracking so you can
actually lock onto a subject in your
frame and focus on not running into
something or falling over or if you're
on one wheel not crashing and the gimbal
will always keep your subject framed up
which is pretty amazing and really
unlocks a lot of really cool shots
so this is huge actually this is a
paradigm shift this is completely
rethinking gimbals no more balancing and
no more up and down wobble it's a true
stabilized system this is enough to go
out and buy this camera if I got two
more Paradigm shifts for you what the
heck could they be
this camera comes with an external
wireless monitor using dji's proprietary
wireless video transmission system that
lets you transmit video up to 20
000 feet with low latency what's so
special about Wireless right we've had
Wireless smart cameras before yes you
have but you have to go out and you have
to spend a lot of money to get special
systems you have to attach them to your
camera body you have to figure out how
you're going to power them you got to
run an HDMI cable or an HD STI cables
basically right now we're running
Wireless is a pain in the butt and it's
something that you're doing on almost
every big film set even most small film
sets now you're trying to do some sort
of Wireless solution and that's one of
those things where you look at what the
camera companies are making and no one's
addressing it but DJ I was like you know
what we've got gimbals now on our camera
let's take it a step further the
wireless is built into the camera it's
powered by the camera and there's no
interference issues it's just a rock
solid image it's a rock solid image I
can go wherever I want I can go wherever
I want and go I can literally go
upstairs on the other side of our brick
wall all right we're here we gotta point
this at something so we can tell that
it's moving all right there we go let's
go on a journey
still going
sorry Jake one second I have to get this
shot okay and action all right perfect
love it okay what's up oh wait Jake I'm
noticing I'm noticing a problem uh we're
a little Overexposed you know sorry let
me just let me just drop the aperture
down a little bit here that's right I
have full control over the camera with
this wireless monitor it's not just
wireless video this is full access to
the camera I can literally take the
handles off the side of the camera and
stick them on the side of the Monitor
and control the camera with a joystick
hit all the buttons I mean I can Stir It
Up use the touchscreen here change the
white balance change the iso change the
shutter speed the fact that this is not
just wireless video but full wireless
control full mirrored wireless control
is this the perfect camera you know it
might be actually if you guys have seen
the perfect camera video we did like in
2018 I think it was this camera
legitimately addresses like every single
point of that it's pretty amazing but
you know what the real test is let's go
outside and let's see how far we can
walk before we lose signal I'm fully
expecting the video to cut out shortly
here because it's passing through like
five brick walls
it's still going oh no it's still going
this is a little scary yeah the actual
camera is in that building in like a
unit in the middle of the building and I
still have video feed of it I can still
pull Focus
uh no it's still working
okay
[Music]
still working
all right we're barely getting it it's
still there
you can see it a little bit all right
Point made right Point's been made yeah
we're all the way down
it's gonna take us like five minutes to
walk back
so those are two pretty cool Paradigm
shifts but while we're walking back to
get to that third one let me explain to
you a little bit of uh what I was
looking for when I built my perfect
camera in 2018. one thing that we've all
had to deal with is focus even when
you're shooting with autofocus you still
have to deal with focus in the moment
you want to make artistic decisions with
your focus there's a moment you run into
trouble currently the only way to pull
focus on most systems is to reach onto
the barrel of the lens and twist it or
to set up a system of gears and motors
to control your focus pulling with
somebody then turning a knob that's a
huge pain in the butt every time you
swap the lens you have to set up new
gears you have to set up the motor you
have to possibly recalibrate it and on
top of that you need to set up another
external wireless video monitor so that
the person pulling Focus can see what's
going on and all that just a stare at a
screen and try to guess if something's
in Focus or not that takes us to the
third paradigm shift
[Music]
so this camera comes with a lidar and
the lidar lets you turn on something
called a depth waveform on both monitors
here this depth waveform is basically a
top-down view of your scene so it's
basically shooting out like an infrared
laser it's scanning the scene and it's
using that to determine its distance at
this kind of like cross-sectional level
and it displays that as a waveform on
the monitor I cannot overstate how this
small Innovation is totally changed
Focus pulling for me because in the past
when somebody's walking to the camera
away from the camera you're staring at
the screen trying to figure out if
you're in focus and oftentimes trying to
figure out if you've thrown it a little
too far or you've thrown it a little too
close and which direction do you have to
go to adjust because if they're not
quite in Focus sometimes it's hard to
tell where you actually ended up this
eliminates all guesswork 100 of
guesswork you are literally just looking
at a top-down view of your scene like a
cross section and just setting that
Focus line wherever you want it to be
and as people move around you just
follow it with that Focus line that's
what you want as a filmmaker you don't
want an actor to just like pour out
their guts into a performance only for
somebody like there's a little little
soft I missed it
that's gone that's a thing of the past
here on top of that there's some extra
tools that make it super cool so by
adding the slider not only did DJI
change the game of focus pulling but
they've come up with a bunch of new
visual languages that you can use to
make your focus playing game perfect so
you have the waveform amazing tool you
can actually use autofocus to have it
highlight in area pixels but you can
disable the autofocus Focus pulling so
you see your highlighted Zone that you
want to have in Focus as green pixels on
your lidar and then you can move the
focus yourself handy little tool on top
of that they have a hybrid auto focus
pulling system where the camera will
pull Focus it'll even turn the wheel for
you as it automatically tracks the zone
that you selected on the screen or a
person's face and then at any point you
can adjust it so in other words you get
all the power of autofocus all the power
of artistic decisions from manual focus
at the exact same time and you're not
guessing by trying to look at the screen
and squinting like are these pixels
actually sharp doesn't matter anymore
because you got this lidar all these
Paradigm shifts pulled together into one
cohesive package not only do you have a
system that stabilizes like a Steadicam
and a gimbal combined not only do you
have a system that has wireless video
broadcasting out to another control unit
that gives you full control over the
camera not only do you have the ability
to pull Focus remotely with no gears
with no rails it's all just built into
the lens you also have a new way of
visualizing Focus
I even talked about the sensor it's a
full frame sensor it's not a super 35
like no it's full frame so the camera we
have here has a 6K sensor but they also
have an 8K model coming out in the
future dual ISO check out low light you
got 14 stops of dynamic range and the
camera has built-in ND filters letting
you open up the aperture and drop your
shutter speed for nice cinematic images
when you're outside in the sunlight they
can do 120 frames per second at 4K
I mean we'll just take it for granted
that the camera itself is good but it is
things happening here but the actual
camera itself is good too so all of
these things together address pretty
much every single challenge I've faced
when trying to build out digital cameras
for shooting videos this is my go-to
cinematic camera right now because just
me and one other person we can get crazy
shots we can make it look like we have
dollar tracks we can make it look like
we have a Steadicam like the camera
literally lets us do all the things that
we want to do with a camera system it is
checking all the boxes of a perfect
camera for me just doing the gimbal
alone would have been crazy but they're
like no no
second special
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
all right so with any review video at
some point you should talk about the
cons all right let's talk about the
downsides so here's my my wishes for
what future versions of this camera
might hold or you know this camera with
firmware updates who knows I'd love to
see more official DJI lenses that are a
little more built out for Cinema so a
little bit smaller minimum focal
distances a little bit more telephotos
in the in the set a 16 mil that covers
full frame because frankly with this
camera system I think you're just going
to want to use these lenses you can use
other lenses like it has adapters you
can put e-lenses on there you can put M
lenses on there a good amount of the
e-lenses actually use the internal Focus
motor so you don't have to put any gears
or railings on and to me that's key the
camera comes with Focus Motors if you
want to use other lenses that require
them but I want to make sure I never
have to put rails and gears on my lenses
I always wanted to integrate naturally
with the camera and these are so light
and Tiny that I literally don't have to
rebalance the thing whenever swapping
lenses the other thing I would like to
see is a true Rock codec a true
impressed raw codex the camera does have
prores raw but the best thing about Reds
and Blackmagic cameras are their raw
codecs B raw and red code raw are
amazing they truly lets you get away
with big mistakes on set that turn out
to not be big mistakes in the future
because you can change your raw settings
you really don't have to worry about
those things on set just make sure
enough lights in the camera and it's in
focus and you're good it's not quite the
same thing here with prora's raw DaVinci
resolves and support for pro as raw yet
that's basically it it's like there's
only two things I really want I'm glad
we could give all of you a first look
into this entirely new approach to
camera technology this is a game changer
right here this is going to change how
we shoot our videos it makes me
extremely happy as somebody who's always
tried to shoot small light Crews this
camera solves a bunch of my problems at
least it feels like they made it for me
it feels like they watched my perfect
camera video and then just did that for
me personally so DJI thank you thank you
for making me a perfect camera
and I'm excited for the rest of you out
there to get your hands on this thing
because it's really a wonderful machine
and I'm happy to see the industry
getting pushed forward like it is